so let's see if we can try to factor the
following expression
completely so factor this completely
pause the video and have a go at that
all right now let's work through this
together so the way that i like to think
about it i first try to see is there any
common factor to all the terms and i try
to find the greatest of the common
factor possible common factors to all
the terms
so let's see they're all divisible by 2
so 2 would be a common factor but let's
see they're also all divisible by 4. 4
is divisible by 4 8 is divisible by 4 12
is divisible by 4 and that looks like
the greatest common factor they're not
all divisible by x so i can't throw an x
in there so what i want to do is factor
out a 4. so i could rewrite this as four
times now what would it be four times
what well if i factor a four out of four
x squared i'm just going to be left with
an x squared if i if i factor a four out
of negative eight x negative 8x divided
by 4 is negative 2 so i'm going to have
negative 2x
and if i factor a 4
out of negative 12 negative 12 divided
by 4 is negative
3.
now am i done factoring well it looks
like i could factor this thing a little
bit more can i think of two numbers that
add up to negative 2 and when i multiply
it i get negative 3. and since when i
multiply i get a negative value one of
them is going to be positive and one of
them is going to be negative i could
think about it this way
a plus b is equal to negative 2
a times b needs to be equal to negative
3. so let's see a could be equal to
negative 3 and b could be equal to 1
because
negative 3 plus 1 is negative 2 and
negative 3 times 1 is negative 3. so i
could rewrite all of this as
4
times
x
plus negative 3 or i could just write
that as x minus 3
times
x plus 1
x plus 1. and now i have actually
factored this completely
let's do another example
so let's say that we had the expression
negative 3 x squared plus 21x minus 30.
pause the video and see if you can
factor this completely
all right now let's do this together so
what would be the greatest common factor
so
let's see they're all divisible by 3. so
you could factor out a 3. but let's see
what happens if you factor out a 3. this
is the same thing as 3 times
well negative 3x squared divided by 3 is
negative x squared
21x divided by 3 is 7x so plus 7x and
then negative 30 divided by 3 is
negative 10.
you could do it this way but having this
negative out on the x squared term still
makes it a little bit confusing on how
you would factor this further you can do
it but it still takes a little bit more
of a of a mental load so instead of just
factoring out a 3 let's factor out a
negative 3. so we could write it this
way if we factor out a negative 3 what
does that become well then if you factor
out a negative 3 out of this term you're
just left with an x squared if you
factor out a negative 3
from this term 21 divided by negative 3
is negative 7 x
and if you factor out a negative 3 out
of negative 30 you're left with a
positive 10.
positive 10.
and now let's see if we can factor this
thing a little bit more can i think of
two numbers
where if i were to add them i get to
negative 7
and if i were to multiply them i get 2
10
and let's see they'd have to have the
same sign because their product is
positive so see a could be equal to
negative 5 and then b is equal to
negative 2.
so i can rewrite this whole thing as
equal to negative 3 times x plus
negative 5 which is the same thing as x
minus 5 times x plus negative 2 which is
the same thing as x
minus 2. and now we have factored
completely